des dauphins dressés pour protéger les
bases navales en mer Baltique voici
l'ultimarm utilisé par la Russie car
Moscou prend très au sérieux la menace
des forces spéciales ukrainiennes les
dauphins positionnés en dernier recours
servirait à détecter des nageurs qui
auraient réussi à franchir toute une
rangée d'obstacles le 23 juin le
ministère de la Défense britannique
révélé que depuis l'été 2022
l'amiroterus avait notamment renforcé la
sécurité du port stratégique de
Sébastopol en Crimée les satellites
espion occidentaux eux avaient détecté
un doublement des enclos flottants pour
mammifères marins le premier rôle des
dauphins est de protéger la basse
principale de la flotte contre des
saboteurs sous-marins les dauphins l'ont
nés par exemple patrouille à l'entrée de
la baie et signale tout intrusion au
site de surveillance côtière ils sont
capables de tuer l'ennemi tout seul avec
une muselière spéciale équipée d'une
pique d'après l'ancien dresseur
militaire russe Victor baranet certains
mammifères déployés en Syrie en 2016
auraient même reçu une formation de
kamikaze ils emporté une mine magnétique
qu'il pouvait coller contre la coque
d'un sous-marin et les dauphins
pouvaient même être largués depuis un
hélicoptère pour certaines missions aux
États-Unis l'expérimentation de dauphins
par l'US Navy remonte à 1960 mais
l'usage des mammifères n'est pas une
première durant la Première Guerre
mondiale déjà des pigeons voyageurs
reliés les défenseurs du Fort de Vaux à
l'état-major français
[Musique]